[Applaudissements]
alors je vais parler beaucoup dans ce
toc de complexité jeu même parler de
hacker la complexité parce que je pense
qu'elle est au coeur du bien vivre
ensemble
alors oui je suis un acteur alors s'il
vous plaît ne paniquez pas voter les
femmes le risque absolument rien je vais
pas vous faire de chantage à la sortie
effectivement malheureusement quand on
pense à hacker on pense très souvent pas
quelqu'un de malveillant
là où la classe c'est vraiment quelqu'un
qui est motivée par le fait de
déconstruire un système pour l'améliorer
et c'est quelque chose que j'ai
découvert personnellement très tôt
j'étais encore au maroc très adolescent
de parents enseignants qui ont mis une
partie de leurs économies pour nous
acheter un ordinateur ils ont eu un peu
de flair en fait le premier jour où
l'ordinateur est rentré à la maison
dans l'heure qui a suivi je les plantes
et je les plans des parce que
extrêmement curieux j'ai pas pu
m'empêcher de bidouiller doux toucher à
la configuration testée des lignes de
commande et cetera en tout cas son est
suivie une des journées les plus longues
de ma vie parce qu'il fallait réparer
cette machine et si je suis devant vous
ce soir c'est que a priori j'ai réussi à
remettre la machine de guerre sinon mon
père vous l'aurez compris voilà j'ai
découvert en tout cas l'euphorie que
pouvait procurer procurait le fait
d'aller au delà de cette peur qu'on peut
avoir très souvent quand on a des
systèmes des boîtes noires et qu'on a
peur en fait de toucher à ces systèmes
qui semble fonctionner en toute
autonomie
j'ai fait une deuxième découverte des
années plus tard
à ce moment là j'étais enseignant
vacataire à l'université dans un
département de mathématiques et
d'informatique
je discutais énormément avec les
enseignants un en particulier qui m'a
fait découvrir un auteur qui est très
peu connue en france stéphane heulot
pascoe je ne sais pas s'il ya des gens
dans la salle qui le connaissent c'est
écrit m'ont totalement foudroyé et ça
m'a propulsé dans le monde de la
complexité justement où j'ai découvert
des concepts barbares comme le
cette d'émergence le concept
d'organisation récursive le concept
hologramme atik et c est ma manière de
voir les choses a totalement changé à
partir de ce moment alors on peut se
poser la question pourquoi ac et la
complexité premiers éléments parce que
la complexité nous éclaire de manière
assez limpide sur le lien entre le local
et le global
je vous prends un exemple très simple si
vous regardez une volée d'oiseaux
vous avez souvent l'impression que c'est
une entité homogène
c'est un ensemble qui se déplace et on
est très souvent tentés de croire qu'il
ya un leader quelque part qui dit à tous
les autres oiseaux tourne-à-droite
tourner à gauche il faut foncer
alors que dans les faits il n'en est
absolument rien en fait chaque oiseau
localement un ensemble de règles très
simples qui le suit et qui permet de
voir émerger
c'est le principe d'émergence une entité
globale qui est qui semble être tout à
fait autonome deuxième partie pourquoi
encore une fois à quai la complexité
parce que comme tout concept
scientifique très fort c'est un concept
qui est en train de sortir du monde de
la science vers le grand public est très
souvent quand cela se produit on déforme
les mots il n'y a pas un jour qui passe
sans qu'on utilise nous-mêmes ou que les
politiciens ou que les athlètes ou les
journalistes utilisent ce terme mais
très souvent le terme complexe devient
un trait texte pour ne pas affronter les
défis
c'est un sujet très complexe on va
laisser de côté buvant un verre ensemble
ça va mieux se passer et je peux vous
donner un exemple encore qui illustre
très bien la relativité d'einstein tout
est relatif c'est une phrase qui une
fois qu'elle est sortie du monde de la
relativité est devenue extrêmement
dangereuse parce que tout d'un coup
l'opinion de monsieur tout le monde
devient un peu l'équivalent de celle
d'un chercheur après tout tout est
relatif troisième point pourquoi ac et
la complexité
parce que hacker renvoie forcément à la
technologie et je pense qu'il est
important de mesurer la place que la
technologie a pris aujourd'hui dans nos
vies faisant un retour en arrière il ya
encore quelques années nous avions des
ordinateurs qu'ils aient la superficie
d'un stade de foot puis on a eu les
ordinateurs sous forme de tour puis on a
eu les ordinateurs portables puis les
téléphones portables puis les montres
connectés
puis petit à petit nous avons même
maintenant des puces qu'on peut
s'intégrer on peut commencer à voir en
fait la technologie fusionné avec le
corps humain et on va même jusqu'à dire
aujourd'hui les chercheurs nous démontre
que la technologie est en train de nous
modifier les nouvelles générations ont
une zone du pouce qui est totalement
disproportionnée par rapport aux
générations précédentes savez pourquoi
les téléphones portables c'est
extrêmement intéressant et donc il faut
voir dans la technologie
je vais utiliser par exemple le principe
de récursivité organisationnel un
produit de notre complexité mais à son
tour est le produit de la complexité
dans notre quotidien et on peut du coup
voir dans la technologie un laboratoire
dans lequel on peut s'entraîner pour
appréhender les défis de la complexité
il faut pas oublier que nous sommes des
héritiers de descartes et que nous avons
encore cette vision où on décompose les
problèmes pour mieux l'analyser les
analyser et tout d'un coup on perd en
fait la vision d'ensemble
alors plus concrètement personnellement
je ne serai plus l'enfant dont je vous
ai parlé ou tout début
par contre j'ai un petit garçon et quand
beaucoup d'adultes
je me pose la question de la
transmission pour tous les challenge
avenir que cette génération va devoir
faire face et je pense que une des
manières de les aider c'est de les
équiper de ce type d'outil que vous
voyez derrière moi alors pour ceux qui
le connaissent pas c'est ce qu'on
appelle des raspberry pas y céder petit
ordinateur qui tiennent dans le creux
d'une main ça coûte une dizaine de
dollars une dizaine d'euros
c'est totalement open source c'est à
dire on peut savoir exactement ce qu'il
ya dedans comment ça marche et on peut
faire une pléthore de projets mais des d
un âge assez assez jeune on peut
imaginer on peut construire avec ça des
voitures autonomes qui se déplace on
peut imaginer des systèmes de
vidéosurveillance
on peut aussi imaginer par exemple des
projets de systèmes d'irrigation
automatique
on va avoir des capteurs qui vont
analyser la température qui vont
analyser la typologie du sol qui va
juste avoir le bon flux d'eau qui va
aller dans le sol et vous imaginez si on
fait travailler nos enfants sur ce type
de projet ce qui va être intéressant
c'est que tout d'un coup les enfants
vont se poser des questions en termes de
météorologie
de biologie de physique parce qu'il ya
des capteurs faut bien comprendre
comment ça marche de coding ce qu'il va
y avoir du code mais aussi
d'infrastructures d'architecturé comment
tout cela comme unique entre lui et je
pense que c'est là où nous avons un
véritable enjeu à quai la complexité
c'est donner à nos enfants
localement la capacité d'architecturé un
meilleur vivre ensemble à quai la
complexité c'est aussi leur donner la
capacité d'appréhender tous les enjeux
par exemple de la souveraineté
on en parle beaucoup dans l'ère
numérique une suivre un thé nouméa
numérique c'est-à-dire maîtriser son
destin numérique ne peut pas être choqué
quelque chose qui va descendre dont il
faut assurer localement et pour
l'assurer localement il faut que les
enfants soient capables de comprendre
d'appréhender de hacker la société qui
les entoure
alors bien entendu cela va se faire avec
beaucoup de paradoxes
il aura beaucoup de paradoxes à
affronter et quelque part j'ai envie de
dire tant mieux je vais même si tu es un
physicien knicks bord et je vais
m'arrêter sur cette citation qui disait
qu'il est merveilleux de rencontrer un
paradoxe
nous avons la preuve que des progrès
peuvent être faits merci
[Applaudissements]